protect it like it's America and we
should help them like it's America
Protect it to the core and 700 bucks per
person is not doing that The Rock yes
the rock of all people I get most of my
deep philosophical and religious uh and
patriotic Notions from The Rock uh he
was on Joe Rogan and he talked a bit
about this was in the context of talking
about the the horrific fire in Maui from
a couple months ago but talked about
what brings America together in the
middle of the ocean that's created
Islands yeah and that's America 50th
state yeah it's wild but if we are if
that is America we should treat it like
it's America and we should protect it
like it's America and we should help
them like it's America Protect it to the
core and 700 bucks per person is not
doing that at all a one-time payment
it's so insulting and so insane in the
light of all this public knowledge of
the amount of money that we're sending
to other countries yeah well you know
what we did on this fund just so you
know it's $1,200 per month oh that's
great it's great for months and uh
anyone who's verified and you know with
Polynesian culture um there's it's U
there's a lot of people in the house at
times like aunties and uncles and
grandparents so there's some houses that
are getting four five $6,000 that's
great that's really great yeah yeah
that's something and again should be
coming from the government and it could
be done it's not something that couldn't
be done I mean it's something that
everybody would support take care of our
own take care of our own first yeah I
mean what other what are we if we're not
a country if we're not a it's the same
thing with family right like you would
take care of your family first I take
care of my family first take care of our
American people it's a community we
should be a community and we're so
divided and polarized right now and I
think a lot of that is accentuated by
social media it's funny Rogan saying
take care of us first like that's Donald
Trump stuff Rogan did not vote for
Donald Trump either time as far as I
know I don't think he voted either time
if I'm not mistaken but I'm happy to be
corrected on that but the point the
overriding point is yes what's happening
right now is we have we have so many
people that can now blatantly see that
our government is not taking care of us
first that we are now fighting with each
other over whatever the scraps are and
that is not good and that doesn't mean
we can't do good in the world you know
it doesn't mean you have to Nation build
everywhere I think that large experiment
is over and most of the people who were
for nation building uh are in the dust
bin of history at this point but if we
are not the world's leader guess what
China gladly will be and China might
just take over California because
they're they've got XI jingping in San
Francisco literally today and they
cleaned up the cities for him so we
might just start selling our cities and
our states to China do you think the
world would be better off if China had a
bigger role and the United States had a
lesser role again that doesn't mean we
have to bomb every country but the but
if we could get back to what our
national ethos is and what the purpose
of America was and if we could spread
those ideas not by gun but by by through
culture and through goodness and through
teaching people what Freedom really
means that would be good for basically
everybody